in times of crisis
information is king how we get it has
only become more varied and rich
from printed dreams to radio i send my
greeting
as the king emperor from tv screens to
digital devices
how we access our news is more plural
and colorful than ever before
that is until facebook flicks a switch
australia was the battleground a new law
here will force big
tech to pay the creators of news content
for publishing it on their platforms
not acceptable said facebook and its
response was radical
a total ban of news content in australia
published
viewed or shared it's not something that
we've done um
lightly i think there's a real um
misunderstanding
about how how our platform actually
operates publishers not just in
australia but around
but around the world they they have the
choice if they want to post news on
facebook
the australian response was apoplectic
this is outrageous
and unacceptable we expect that facebook
will fix these actions immediately and
never repeat them again
not least because there was collateral
damage facebook also blocked public
service information the fire brigade
even a domestic abuse charity
disgraceful say the journalists affected
particularly during a pandemic
without being able to have fact-checked
quality
information available to them via the
pages of many outlets like the sydney
morning herald
um we believe it absolutely will lead to
misinformation
conspiracy theorists google faced the
same threat and took the opposite
approach
striking a deal with rupert murdoch's
news corps empire a small cost perhaps
to avoid the fallout
this might feel like a battle on the
other side of the world but it is
remarkable that anyone who wants to
access
an australian news source on facebook
now
can't and while there's been years of
escalating tensions between government
and big tech this really feels like a
key moment
where that spilled over into action and
retaliation
many see it as an outright attack on
free speech
and even democracy itself
and that could totally alter the road to
regulation putting big tech under more
pressure than ever before
similar laws are already being discussed
in the eu the gauntlet thrown down
to legislators worldwide i just i'm i'm
i'm almost speechless which is quite
rare for a politician
over this it's it is one of the most
idiotic corporate but also deeply
disturbing corporate moves
of our lifetimes i think it's a move
that will
anger rather than cow legislators around
the globe
that battle will take time in the short
term it's consumers who'll lose most
this is the sort of world first
experiment that we've just had and it's
kind of blown up
so you know going forward if we wanted
to learn better from it how can we have
a more
amicable cordial negotiating process
that also takes into account all of the
other stakeholders which in this case
are the millions of users in a country
this could all dramatically backfire for
facebook if
users take issue amidst a rich history
of media
this remains the most modern of
challenges helen and smith sky news